How to go from small talk to deep
conversation? I'm Chad and let's get started.
So, through my work I've gotten to facilitate
thousands of conversations with hundreds of
thousands of people about all sorts of topics.
And in that work, I've learned a couple really
key lessons that have helped me create more
conversations that matter. And so in this video,
I'm going to unpack and start with sharing
a story about Amanda, student in a program
that I was facilitating- training that I was
facilitating, at San Jose State University
2 days ago actually. And I'm gonna
share the relearning or "aha" that I had
in relation to how do you take conversations
from small talk, which very few people like,
to real talk, to deeper conversation in a
comfortable, natural way. And so in this video, I'm
going to share this main paradigm that I learned.
But first, Amanda, so I'm facilitating this program
and Amanda unmuted- it was virtual and Amanda
unmuted and shared something about herself
and I realized she only spoke for about 5
seconds. But, in that 5 seconds, I asked the rest
of the group, I asked, "Amanda, are you okay being put
on the spot for a minute?" And I asked the rest
of the group, "What did we just learn about Amanda?"
And even though she only spoke for 5 seconds,
we were able to come up with more than 5
things that we learned about Amanda, and yet
most people, in that setting, the conversation would
have just fell flat, and yet in my mind, one of the
most powerful tools to go from small talk to
real talk or small talk to deeper conversation
is to follow that curiosity, but in a very specific
direction which I'll explain in a moment. Because
a big part of my job is inviting people to stretch
outside of their comfort zone, I believe that every
year, I need to do at least 1 big thing that
stretches me outside of my own comfort zone. And so
last year, I was on a 10-day kayak camping retreat
in the middle of the woods, no self-service for
over a week in total wilderness. Paddling from
site to site where we were camping and there
was a lot of alone time. There was a lot of time
to think and an "aha" showed up for me which is
this graph that we're gonna put up right here.
So, from a spectrum of small talk over here over
to real talk over here, you're watching this video
because you want to be on this side of the graph.
Now, to add 1 dimension to this, I would say
the most powerful tool to move from one place
to the other is curiosity. And so, we draw another
line coming down from a level of high curiosity
to a level of low curiosity. The tool that I would
love for you to employ is follow your vertical
curiosity. And what I mean by that is go up with
your curiosity as opposed to what most of us do
is horizontal curiosity shopping. So, we kind
of like bounce from topic to topic to topic,
as opposed to going really deep and intentional
with 1 thought by listening very deeply
and continuing to be curious about that element.
Kind of circling down that vertical curiosity
is the easiest tool that you can just
choose to do to go from
small talk to real talk. Now, let me be really
clear, for me the definition, as far as small talk
has nothing to do with the topic of conversation.
So, typically when we think about small talk we
think about the weather or where you're from or
what do you do. I would say that small talk has
everything to do with the process and the way that
you're having the conversation. 2 meteorologists
talking about the weather might not be small
talk. It might be a really good conversation.
And so, we can't eliminate or judge whether a topic
is worthy of being called "deeper conversation"
just by the topic of conversation. And so, the
process really is following- that makes real
conversation happen, is following your genuine
curiosity vertically, not horizontally and
also listening. Curiosity and great questions are
worthless without these 2 appendages on the side
of our head that allow us to retain information,
understand it and potentially spit it back because
when we listen really well, we can get curious
about many more things. And so in particular,
going back to who we'll call Amanda from San Jose
State University, the piece that she shared she-
asked everybody to go grab an object that had
some meaning to them and she brought back this
little tiny frame with a constellation in it. And
she just shared, "I'm not really into zodiac signs
but I'm a cancer." And she said like maybe 1 other
phrase and that was it. There was no other context.
And yet when I asked the group, "what did you learn
from Amanda?" They were able to come up with 5 or
more things, right. She's kind into zodiac but
not really, but knows enough to be dangerous.
She's a cancer, she's a comfortable enough to
share in front of the group, right. So, now we
start to travel into things that she didn't say
verbatim, but were present in the actual group.
And so, there's some massive value in thing in
realizing that if you listen really intentionally,
what you're curious about will change because what
you hear will actually fundamentally be different.
I've unpacked this in a couple other videos
about how to start conversations with new people
that you can check out right here, but one of my- by
far my favorite features of conversation is this
idea that dialogue is exponential. Conversation
and connection is exponential and here's exactly
what I mean by that. So, if I learn about this
plant, right. If I learn that it used to grow
in a greenhouse 15 minutes away, if that's
all I learned about this plant, right, I can ask
who works at that greenhouse, who started that
greenhouse, what's the story behind it, what does
the owner care about, right. We could go on for- this
video could be unnecessarily long coming up with
questions about the story of just a plant. Human
beings are way more complex and so, when you- when
somebody speaks for 10 seconds, almost certainly
you can learn at least 3 things from them.
And then if you ask a question about any of these
3 things, you'll learn 3 more things. And
then you ask a question about any of those and
you've got 3 more topics. And so, you can see
how conversation is exponential and yet typically,
I think this is really important because with
people that we're close to in our personal lives,
but also especially colleagues in our work lives,
we follow like one curiosity path a little bit. We
go horizontal curiosity. We kind of like learn all
the facts about somebody right here, but we never
get past like 5 layers deep of curiosity. And
so, you're watching this video because you want
to go from small talk to deeper conversation,
this is the way to do it. Break past that barrier
because usually we go about 3 layers deep
in curiosity and then we put somebody in a box and
they stay in that box and our curiosity dies. And,
you know, just before recording actually I was
leading a workshop for Rutgers University and
somebody asked a question about when you work
with colleagues for 10 plus years you feel like
you know everything about them, even though
realistically you only know 2 percent of
their world and yet you put them in a box.
You don't- if you work somebody for 10 years,
it was probably in the 1st year that they landed
in the box. It was either like, "He's the funny guy,
he's always a jokester." "He's the curmudgeon who's
always cranky and has nothing positive to say in
a meeting." We put people in these boxes and
that limits or puts a ceiling on our curiosity,
and prevents that vertical curiosity from
piercing through. And I would say to take
a personal note from this when Will, my
co-founder and partner, really taught me this.
When my curiosity is not present with Kate,
my wife, our relationship is dead, right .When I
am not curious about who Kate is there is no
progression, there's no relationship moving
forward in that sense. The coolest part though is
that curiosity is a choice. It's a choice and it's
also kind of like a muscle. The more you use it the
more easy it is to use. The more curious you are,
the more easy it is to be curious. There's this
like awesome cyclical effect. But you're watching
this video to go from small talk to deeper
conversation and so really all you have to do is
be curious 3 times today and then 3 times
tomorrow, and the more days you go on being curious,
following that curiosity with questions, the deeper
conversations you'll find yourself having. And if
you're asking rather than random curiosities from
your brain, if you're asking about what somebody
has just shared with you from what you've listened,
the conversation will very quickly move from small
talk to real talk. If you enjoyed this video,
it turns out that my job is helping people
create conversations that matter. Will and I wrote
a book about it it's called "Ask Powerful Questions:
Create Conversations That Matter." There's a link
below with a free excerpt from it. There's also
this thing called Amazon, I've heard of it recently,
that actually carries books, believe it or not. They
sell them on the internet, it's amazing. Awesome
hanging out on cyberspace with you. Have an awesome day.